bien
[Música]
en la vida
cuando hay un momento crítico uno mira
para adelante
y mira para atrás para adelante que se
me viene encima como lo voy a afrontar
y para atrás como vivían hasta ahora y
en qué forma me ayuda a esto a vivir mi
futuro
mi momento crítico es ahora
hace pocos meses falleció mi marido
compañero de 60 años de vida
la verdad no pensé que la viudez me
fuera a resultar tan difícil
es cierto que las raíces de dos árboles
que han ido creciendo juntos tanto
tiempo entrelazándose enrocándose
pero la cosa no pasaba por ahí
creo que lo que pasó tiene otra metáfora
estábamos los dos sobre un trampolín
al quedarme yo sola
me quedé sin el impulso sin el embrión
sin la vibración síncrona que nos
disparaba
al mundo de proyectos y de aventuras
miro para otros
y veo mi vida muy larga y completa
miro para adelante y veo la necesidad de
ir cerrando abrochando a botón 'no
de esto les quiero hablar a ustedes hoy
de la importancia de cerrar y de
distintas formas de ir haciéndolo
lo hago usando ejemplos de proyectos que
jalonaron mi vida
octubre 1957
desde la azotea de mi casa nueva york vi
pasar una y otra vez en el cielo
era el primer satélite artificial
que habían largado al espacio los rusos
daba la vuelta a la tierra cada 90
minutos yo acababa de llegar a nueva
york- flamante licenciada en física de
la uba para estudiar en la universidad
de columbia
quién sería mi marido
yo no lo conocía todavía
estaba trabajando a raja cincha justo en
ese momento desarrollando un máster que
es un amplificador cuántico que iba a ir
montado en el primer satélite
norteamericano ese satélite se lanzó en
enero
pero ya los rusos habían ganado la
carrera de espacio tres meses antes
spot take desencadenó un vendaval un
verdadero vendaval en los eeuu que
pasaba con la ciencia en los eeuu si los
rusos tenían la ventaja en el espacio
rápidamente se aprobaron fondos en el
congreso
y se convocó a las mejores mentes del
país para que efectuaran una reforma
radical en la enseñanza de la ciencia la
propuesta era mejorar la educación en
ciencia de los jóvenes y así sacarles la
ventaja a los rusos
son proyectos del país entero que duró
una decena de años
es el momento que me tocó vivir y que
marcó mi carrera profesional
la enseñanza tradicional es y así es
como aprendí yo
presentaba la ciencia como una serie de
leyes por ejemplo las leyes de newton
que nos han sido entregadas como dios le
entregó las tablas de la ley a moisés
la bandada de proyectos ostos
buscaba presentar la ciencia como un
proceso semejante al que sigue un
científico
que va investigando y descubriendo cosas
la idea era que los alumnos emprendieron
pequeños proyectos científicos
formulando preguntas
buscando explicaciones formulando
hipótesis confirmando las o no
tengo un puñado de bicarbonato
le agrego un poco de vinagre y sal en
burbujas que son las burbujas
puedo apreciar las
y si las apresó en un recipiente y le
acercó un fósforo encendido la llama se
aviva se apaga que da igual le puedo
poner un nombre hay ese gas
mi rol en el esfuerzo post food net
fue desarrollar programas y cursos para
docentes en donde se presentaba la
ciencia con actividades como las que les
dejamos de describir este tipo de cosas
esto iba de la mano con programas de
investigación sobre las ideas que los
alumnos traían al aula y cómo se podían
trabajar para ayudarles a aprender mejor
todo esto para mí ha quedado atrás pero
se me pregunto cómo se cerró
esa etapa se cerró
entregando gente
y pasando la antorcha
porque los materiales la filosofía los
resultados de las investigaciones todo
eso subsiste en el trabajo profesional
de colegas jóvenes
es todo un tiempo
resultó claro que la ola que se había
desencadenado con la reforma en la
educación en la ciencia se salía del
aula y llevado a otras orillas a
zoológicos campamentos museos
a mí me tocó
barrena da la ola en california en los
años 80
hasta un museo interactivo
un museo interactivo es un lugar donde
lo que se expone no son objetos valiosos
sino fenómenos
que el visitante puede explorar con
actividades ya preparadas
o sea que lo valioso son los fenómenos
que se exploran ahora museos
interactivos de ciencia hoy día existen
a granel a en el mundo entero pero en
aquel momento al comienzo de los 80 nos
estábamos inventando de cero
en hemos sido desarrollamos varias
exposiciones que viajaron por
norteamérica europa más allá
cada exposición en un proyecto con todas
las particularidades de lo que es un
proyecto que empieza con una idea sigue
con el desparramo de ideas
algunas nos llevan a nada
y otras flores en otros se van por
caminos impensados otras aparecen de
casualidad
el proyecto va creciendo avanzando
abriéndose
pero llegó un momento en que se apagó la
plata
o se acabó el tiempo
esto no lo podemos costear lo
abandonamos esto cuesta demasiado hay
que dejarlo de lado
y así vamos descartando y cerrando hasta
que llega el día del estreno y la
muestra se inaugura
cerrar este tipo de proyectos o quiere
decir que se ha logrado un producto
final que se lanza al mundo por ejemplo
se publicó un libro se abre la
exposición nació un chico
se da una charla tel
al mirar el conjunto de mi vida
me di cuenta que se rasca un poquito por
acá me aparece un proyecto rasca un poco
por acá
apareció otro proyecto lo mejor grande a
lo mejor chico pero algo que se abrió
floreció y se cerró
tengo esta idea esta imagen de mi vida
como un árbol digamos un pino
que del tronco va alargando ramas
ramitas agujas
y va creciendo
se abre se cierran con la copa y que de
una estructura armoniosa
pero el detalle de la estructura es
igual a la estructura misma o sea que el
pino es un gran proyecto está hecho de
un sinfín de pequeños proyectos
ahora bien con esta imagen de la vida
un proyecto formado de un sinfín de
proyectos si el proyecto se empezó a
abrir así como fue abriéndose se tiene
que sacar
esto quiere decir
que en mi vida octagenaria ya no es hora
de ir abriendo proyectos nuevos sino de
ir cerrando los que todavía están había
rotos
yo tengo entre manos el cierre de vidas
queridas por ejemplo
mi padre lideró en los años 60 una
expedición arqueológica argentina a lo
que fue el antiguo egipto
y trajo piezas que se exhiben en una
sala que montamos en el museo de
historia natural de la ciudad de la
plata
esa sala está abierta al público
pero para mí
falta un libro ilustrado sobre la vida
de mi padre haciendo esta expedición
para poder terminar mi parte de ese
proyecto
entonces
por qué es tan importante cerrar
si los proyectos no se cierran las ideas
se pierden
los hablamos para darles la forma
necesaria para que sobrevivan
no para enterrar más y olvidarlos
los egipcios mismos
momificaban y se ocultaban justamente
para que el muerto pudiera sobrevivir en
el más allá
visto así
el cierre es liberador
volviendo a la imagen del pino el gran
proyecto de proyectos con buena suerte
lanza semillas que caen en terreno
fértil y engendró un pinar
eso sería la inmortalidad
a mí lo que realmente me importa es mi
vida mi primo mi pino
que sea
una estructura
armoniosa y coherente
poder decir
cierro mi vida y mi vida me sierra
cerrar una vida y terminar con una vida
que cierra
es mucho trabajo
pero el trabajo que vale la pena porque
da sentido al diario vivir
[Aplausos]
[Música]